formula here equals P times 1 plus R
divided by n raised to the N times T
power P is the principle that's what you
put into your investment one represents
like a hundred percent the original
amount R is the interest rate but you
want to convert that into a decimal and
here and here represent the number of
times you're compounding in a year so
for example if it was monthly and would
be 12
okay if its weekly n would be 52 and
then T is a time in years number of
years so let's look at it some examples
say you are investing five thousand
dollars at 8% compounded quarterly for
two years so how would we figure out how
much you would end up with there well
let's see we've got a equals 5,000 is
our starting amount 1 plus 8% is point
zero eight divided by four since you're
compounding quarterly raised to the 4
times 2 okay so if we simplify this we
get 5,000 point zero eight divided by
four is point zero two so that's one
point zero two to the eighth power so
what this means is you're getting two
percent so instead of eight percent
you're getting two percent every quarter
and there's eight quarters in two years
so this is going to be you know
compounding eight times at two percent
each time it's gonna be growing in
compounding on its previous amount so if
we simplify this down let's see what we
get we'll do it on the calculator yet
five thousand one point zero two to the
eighth power
five thousand eight hundred fifty eight
dollars and thirty cents if you round
Kate to the pennies
okay so that's the ending amount that
includes the original investment and the
interest altogether in this figure here
5858 okay